the weather in the window this morning
is snow
unseasonal singular flakes a slow
winter's final shiver
on such an occasion to presume to
eulogize one man
is to pipe up for a whole generation
that crew whose survival was always the
stuff of minor miracle
who came ashore in orange crate coracles
fought ingenious wars finagled
triumphs at sea with flaming decoy boats
and sidestepped torpedoes
husbands to duty they unrolled their
plans
across billiard tables and vehicle
bonnets
regrouped at breakfast what their
secrets were
was everyone's guess and nobody's
business
great grandfathers from birth in time
they became
both in a core and outer case
in a family heirloom of nesting dolls
like evidence of early man their boot
prints stand
in the hardened earth of rose beds and
borders
they were sons of a zodiac out of sync
with the solar year
but turned their minds to the day's big
science
and heavy questions to study their hands
at rest
was to picture maps showing hatched
valleys and
indigo streams schemes of old campaigns
and reconnaissance missions last of the
great avuncular magicians
they kept their best tricks for the
grand finale
disproving immortality and disappearing
entirely major oaks in the woods start
tuning up and skies to come will deliver
their tributes
but for now a cold april's closing
moments
parachute slowly home so by
mid-afternoon
snow is recast as seed heads
and thistle down